mais d'abord on prend tout de suite la
direction de la plage Jean Jaurès à tour
où l'on retrouve romain Delville romain
un bonsoir après l'annonce aujourd'hui
de l'utilisation du 49 3 pour faire
passer la réforme des retraites les
syndicats voire rouge il décidant en ce
moment de la suite à donner au mouvement
et bonsoir Florent bonsoir à tous en
fait c'est la deuxième fois aujourd'hui
que les syndicats se retrouvent place
Jean Jaurès puisque ce midi à 12h49 et 3
secondes il s'était déjà retrouvé il y
avait 300 personnes ce midi il y avait
300 personnes ce soir depuis 17h30 un
rassemblement a donc été programmé on
est allé un petit peu prendre le pouls
de la population en effet après
l'utilisation par Elisabeth borne de
l'article 49.3 de la Constitution de
1958 pour faire passer la réforme des
retraites à 64 ans on a croisé Lucas un
jeune enseignant qui selon lui considère
que le gouvernement n'est plus sûr et en
fait lui ça le remobilise après une
faible mobilisation ici dans les rues à
Tours on a aussi croisé Véronique
Véronique adhérente à la CFTC
actuellement au chômage elle dit moi ça
me provoque de la colère et puis
François-Xavier encadrant technique
d'insertion
qui a vraiment me disait-il l'impression
d'un fait du Seigneur et qu'on nous dit
tout simplement de la fermer à mes côtés
Grégoire Hamelin de l'Union
départementale Force Ouvrière bonsoir
Monsieur Hamelin et maintenant que
va-t-il se passer du côté syndical
bonsoir et bien comme vous l'avez si
bien présenté d'abord passer l'effet de
sidération face à cette acte politique
d'une violence et d'une brutalité comme
on a rarement pu le le concevoir depuis
quelques quelques semaines on a eu une
nécrose midi en présentant le 49-3 là on
est face à 49-3 donc la réaction elle
est immédiate ce soir par une première
rassemblement et puis dès dans les
prochains jours demain matin la terre
syndicale départementale à la suite de
la réunion de l'international va décider
des moyens d'action parce qu'on ne peut
pas laisser faire ce gouvernement on ne
peut pas laisser se déni de démocratie
s'installer dans le pays alors que
toujours la population on ne cessera de
le répéter et contre à plus de 70% de ce
projet de réforme des retraites et
aujourd'hui le président et le
gouvernement viennent de retirer au
Parlement le droit de voter sur cette
réforme donc c'est pour nous très
important et des actions vont se suivre
bien sûr dans les jours prochains parce
que justement l'Inter syndical national
est actuellement réunion à Paris depuis
18h30 quelles options sont sur la table
les options qui sont sur la table c'est
bien sûr des manifestations mais ce que
ce que nous on vient d'être de dire au
micro à nos micros HF là derrière nous à
l'instant puisque les prises de parole
viennent de terminer c'est que demain on
va faire tout ce qui est dans notre
possible pour pousser sur les grèves
accompagner ceux qui sont déjà en grève
et puis étendre la grève dans les
endroits où elle n'est pas encore
présente pour faire reculer ce
gouvernement c'est ça ce que nous
recherchons aujourd'hui c'est pour ça
qu'on a programmé ce soir ce
rassemblement pour lancer ce pour lancer
cette alerte pour mobiliser nos troupes
et demain on va affiner en fonction de
des indications qui sortiront de la
National pardon et bien peut-être une
prochaine manifestation qui sera je
pense très proche parce que encore une
fois on ne peut pas laisser passer ce
cette autoritarisme face à un sujet
aussi important que celui des retraites
là vous voyez un Florent un ce midi déjà
l'idée la perspective d'un 49-3 avait
mobilisé les syndicats en particulier
leur représentant ce soir l'acte est
fait et sont plus que jamais mobilisés
merci Romain en direct donc de la plage
Jean Jaurès à Tours ou plus de 300
personnes sont rassemblées et ça
continue donc d'arriver